so Steph we're in your garage I thought
you said we were building stuff right no
I was talking about automating bills
with Google cloud build not that Oh
Google cloud film you mean the one that
lets you orchestrate build stuffs that
run as container exactly and this means
that each built step can do anything a
container can such as executing the
script or a binary so let's look at how
you can use cloud built today to
automate a simple terraform workflow in
a way that you might see a small team
run infrastructure this code
now as a developer I may want to edit
our team's terraform code on a dev
branch to create a new node pool to
accommodate a more CPU intensive
workload then our kubernetes engine
cluster currently allows for I can do
this by updating our terraform code with
a new node pool resource this node pool
will be called Olympic pool and we can
commit those changes to a development
branch this way we can actually use
cloud build to create an approval
workflow as opposed to me actually
applying changes to our infrastructure
from terraform locally we'll do this
using cloud builds notion of build
triggers you'll see that my first build
trigger is set to kick off a build off
of any push to a non master branch
because I changed the terraform
configuration on the dev branch our
build has already been triggered so when
we actually dive into the build you'll
see that it's comprised of two distinct
build steps each running in a container
with the terraform binary the first
build step will initialize terraform and
the second will show us what resources
will be created with the updated code
without actually creating those
resources in this case it will be one
new node pool and we can actually see
this in the logs from those build steps
in the cloud build UI so if we wanted to
we could run more build steps to let's
say run test Suites or actually apply
this to staging environments precisely
that's the idea this is a very simple
illustration both steps are actually
customizable to the point where you
should use them to represent the
workflow that fits your culture so the
two use cases that you just mentioned
they're definitely patterns that you can
adopt so in this demo how will these
changes be realized in production with
another build trigger of course once
I've actually pushed those changes to
the dev branch we're actually going to
create a pull request against the master
branch this is what will actually allow
for our infrastructure to be realized in
production you'll see here that a new
node pool resource is now going to be
created so we'll create that pull
request typically this introduces a
level of approval where we can actually
have someone with the proper permissions
review these changes and give the
approval to actually merge the pull
request
so once we actually merge the pull
request into the master branch we will
actually be invoking our second build
trigger this second build trigger is
actually set up to run on any change to
the master branch as defined here and
you'll see that we actually have a
different cloud build the mo file for
this build trigger in this case what
we're doing here is we're actually
adding a third build step using the same
terraform container image that we had
previously in this case will now be able
to apply those actual infrastructure
changes with terraform so because we've
actually merged dev into master our
build has been triggered to actually run
with those three build steps so you'll
see here that we still have the
terraform container image running init
plan and now we have the third step that
says apply and auto approve so it
happens is because we actually were able
to merge something into master this
build was then triggered to actually
apply those changes as opposed to the
previous build which just ran a plan so
that we could introspect what we wanted
to create so because that build has
actually run let's look in our gke
cluster and we'll see here that the no
pool called Olympic pool is actually
being created Google Cloud bill can
easily make your workflow automated and
help you easily enable continuous
building testing and deployment don't
forget to Like comment and subscribe for
more great Google cloud platform content
[Music]